The joe rogan experience.
I,
uh,
I came just behind you guys and one of
my big regrets is that I never got to
perform with the Ding Ho cause it was so
legendary.
Yeah.
Well it's because the,
the,
the comics were in charge basically,
you know,
booking and the,
all that stuff.
So it was,
it was,
yeah,
it was crazy.
Well that's sort of how the comedy store
used to be except for the booking aspect
of it.
You know,
the comics will never in charge of,
but there was still,
but there's no real crowd control.
There was no,
all comics work in the booth.
Comics would work.
The door,
the comedy store was like,
it's all comics working.
Well this was,
this was,
yeah,
this was pretty even much may ham and
eggs guy a shun Lee.
He ran the Ding Ho and a talked to me
maybe twice.
One night I go out on stage and I'm
doing my character and I,
you know,
I'm full bore,
right.
And then,
um,
I stop and I say,
you know,
hi,
this is my real voice.
I'd like to gut and clean some fish
tonight.
Does anyone have any fish?
You know,
really straight.
I'm saying this in,
my roommate raises his hand and he pulls
out this big fish.
Now the fish have been in the trunk of
his car,
so it's rancid.
Oh No,
I just got the fish and gut and trails
and trails all over the stage.
And this woman just contact vomit as
soon as she smelled it.
Just,
Oh,
so I'm a professional.
I put the mic right down to her from he
or retching over the PA
chicks,
shooken up this fish gut vomit all over
the front of this days.
And then I go,
well thank you.
Good night.
[inaudible]
she was bill Campbell around when
you're,
oh,
this guy,
really sweet guy.
But his act as you know,
talking about,
you know,
relationships,
men go to me,
you know?
Yeah.
It's just guts and fishing.
And he goes,
uh,
you know,
so he,
his act is destroyed because overbook,
this kind of stuff.
So yeah,
very nice,
wholesome kind of heck.
And then I did this and then Sean Lee,
there's only time,
first time he talked to me,
he goes,
he pulls me over to talk to him.
He goes by you weird.
He said,
fuck,
are you weird?
Wow.
What a great boss.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was,
It was like,
I still did this,
you know,
second show,
don't do the fish.
You know,
it's hilarious.
No,
the true shamonic tradition is,
it was explained to me,
um,
by uh,
this Guy Jack hair and he said that the
idea is that you,
you eat the,
the drug,
the plant Mush chaminade a miscarriage
has a very different,
it's not so Simon,
it's some other type of,
what you're shooting for is a Jessica
Mall.
You're should,
the active compound is musket ball and
what its Axon a very different mechanism
actually.
Yeah.
So the mechanism of action of m Anita
Miscarry,
it actually acts as a Gaba agonist.
So it's going to give you more of the
neurotransmitter Gaba.
Whereas siliciden the mechanism of
action that there recently finding,
which I learned a lot about it,
the maps conferences,
mechanism of action of silicide been is
it's actually restricting blood flow to
your default mode network,
part of your brain,
which is your top down control mechanism
in your brain so that you're basically
your mental cerebral filter that allows
you to focus on the day to day mundane
tasks starts to go to sleep and that
happens to be the center that controls
depression and a bunch of other things,
which is why the clinical application is
proving so important and impressive and
all these people,
but that's a totally different mechanism
of action.
Then the Amanita miscarried,
which is basically flooding your brain
with more Gaba from what I understand,
but the musk,
Amal,
is a tricky beast and it doesn't
necessarily come out through your gut.
However,
once it gets processed through your
kidneys and you piss it,
it can be passed up to five times.
They say through different people.
So like I could Piss,
oh sure,
you could drink it,
you could piss,
give it to Brian,
he can take it.
And then Brian could give it to two
other people and everybody will be high
as fuck.
Wow.
What they say?
How'd they know?
How would they know?
Why would they find out?
What are we doing with our lives?
We're sitting around and drinking each
other's pissed to get high.
What are you seeing in fairies?
Cock sucker.
They love drinking,
watching Pluto.
The sure fire way if you really want to
commit is to eat it and then drink.
You're pissed and then you can,
you know,
you feel so stupid.
If it didn't work,
that's true.
Sitting there with piss mouth and not
high and just taking what kind of a
loser ham.
I should just become a republican.
Okay.
I should just go the other way and get
single malt scotch and sneaking some
Cuban cigars and just become an asphalt
or renting a movie while I'm,
but if it works,
eating mushrooms and drinking piss the
fuck am I doing with my life?
You got a dirty garage like I was going
to get to that,
but I had to eat mushrooms and drink my
own piss first.
I'm going to fucking real winter over
here.
I'm going to film it for,
for all the savages.
See what's up because it is perfectly
legal in the US.
I've never met anybody who's had a good
one.
Is it a good a amnesia,
miscarry experience?
Not that I remember anybody telling me
about one.
They've always said like,
oh,
it didn't work for me.
Yeah,
I met somebody who had a weird one and a
not so good one.
Hmm.
I drink tea bro.
Weird and not so good,
but there is pissed drinking so come on.
There's such a tradition around it
though,
you know?
I don't mean that we can all check each
other's pissed by.
Come on,
hop.
He's got it all figured out.
You just got to get a fresh I.
This is in to you and then you pissing
him.
No,
no,
no.
See that's not how it's done.
I forgot to bring cups.
We all thought how it works.
I just pissing your mouth straight from
the spout kind of potty.
We doing here the freshest way to get
his ass in your mouth.
We're going to work this out.
We're going to get high as fuck.
It's exactly what
he's trying to trick us.
Stumble upon this fucking party.
Open up the tent door.
What the fuck?
Piss all over the place.
Bunch of guys,
the Cox,
Nan's.
We're just trying to get enlightenment.
But imagine if it does work and you get
someone really high and they love it and
then you could trick them constantly.
The Yo,
I just cause my pitch.